[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este programa
especial de El Debate de France 24 la
guerra en Ucrania desencadenó una crisis
energética a nivel internacional muchos
fueron los países sobre todo en Europa
que tuvieron que reducir sus
expectativas en cuanto a la transición
energética pero la urgencia por hacer
frente al cambio climático se mantiene
el mundo entero sigue con esta
emergencia latente Cómo hacer entonces
balance entre una necesidad inmediata
como lo es garantizar la energía para
mantener activa la industria y también
la calefacción en el invierno por lo
menos en el invierno boreal o retrasar
la transición energética Pese a que la
crisis medioambiental a nivel mundial
pues no da espera ya estamos en un punto
crítico Cómo se puede priorizar Cómo
hacer balance el año 2022 fue un año de
altibajos económicos para el mundo
entero también altibajos políticos que
han perjudicado la transición energética
qué tanto pues hubo avances vamos a ver
entonces cuáles fueron en el año 2022
Parece ser que fue el año en el que
dimos reversa a toda velocidad en
términos energéticos y en términos de la
transición energética por la coyuntura
que estamos viviendo Y eso evidenció que
la estrategia de la transición es
vulnerable y que los acuerdos pactados
difícilmente se pueden cumplir también
puede ser por falta de compromiso de los
gobiernos para cumplir con estos planes
acordados entonces va a ser necesario
una nueva estrategia a nivel global es
una de las preguntas que pongo sobre la
mesa y cómo pueden ser esos acuerdos o
esos compromisos a nivel internacional y
como está la región de América Latina en
materia energética en esto especial del
debate Entonces vamos a analizar la
crisis energética que desató la guerra
en Ucrania y cómo afectó esos ambiciosos
y necesarios también procesos de
transición energética que muchos
gobiernos subestiman o los dejan un poco
de lado dentro de su orden prioridades
es el año 2023 entonces decisivo para
nuestra lucha contra el cambio climático
lo vamos a analizar en unos minutos y
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a Gustavo umañas él es
subdirector del programa de la ONU para
el medio ambiente en su oficina para
América Latina y el Caribe se encuentra
en Ciudad de Panamá y desde la ciudad de
Austin en el estado de Texas en Estados
Unidos también se conecta Jorge Piñón él
es investigador senior del instituto de
energía y aquí en el estudio de France
24 nos acompaña Luis ferney Moreno él es
profesor investigador del departamento
de derecho minero energético de la
universidad externado que está ubicada
en la ciudad de Bogotá en Colombia
también ustedes ya lo saben son parte de
este debate pueden dejar los comentarios
a través de las redes sociales nos
encuentran a través de Twitter de
Facebook y también de Instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal
la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 todo
pegado todo junto para que nos dejen ahí
sus comentarios en las redes sociales no
olviden también y con esto ya terminó la
introducción que todos nuestros
contenidos están disponibles en las
diferentes plataformas de podcast nos
encuentran en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces preguntándole a
Gustavo El Punto de partida de este
programa para conocer opiniones
generales y para hacer un panorama
general de la situación Gustavo
Bienvenido al programa Gracias por estar
con nosotros y qué lecciones Entonces
nos deja el 2022 en esta crisis
energética que estamos viviendo a raíz
del inicio de la invasión Rusia rusa al
territorio de Ucrania
sobre todo el hecho de que Europa ha
sido altamente dependiente del gas Ruso
y que por eso ha pagado un alto precio
desde el punto de vista Pues de Los
costos energéticos que ha tenido la
guerra y que esa dependencia lo hace
altamente o la hace altamente
vulnerable a los combustibles fósiles y
que si esto está dependencia hubiera
sido
sustituida hace años como se debería
haber hecho a través de las energías
renovables por ejemplo no hubiéramos
tenido pues este altísimo costo Porque
las energías renovables En comparación
con las fósiles sabes por ejemplo lo que
te cuesta un panel solar Y sabes el
costo de la producción de Electricidad
por ejemplo a través de ese panel solar
durante toda la vida útil que tenga ese
panel solar sin embargo con los fósiles
Pues tienes esta altísima volatilidad
que pues no es bueno ni para el
ciudadano ni para la industria ni para
nadie
paso ahora a preguntarle a nuestro
siguiente invitado Jorge en la ciudad de
Austin en el estado de Texas también El
Punto de partida su opinión las
lecciones que deja este 2022 en materia
energética en la transición y lo que nos
deja también como lección esa crisis
desatada por la guerra en Ucrania
bienvenido
gracias gracias Santiago por la
invitación
Sí hemos tenido un contratiempo pero
nosotros por lo menos aquí estamos muy
optimistas y estamos viendo un futuro
muy prometedor quizás no tanto para el
2023 pero sí para el 24 y 25
en los Horizontes en los cuales nosotros
estudiamos son más de tres a cinco años
Horizontes a corto plazo son importantes
pero a largo plazo para nosotros una vez
más 2023 2025 es importante yo creo que
la transición energética está en camino
sí ha tenido algunos contratiempos y va
a tener contratiempos en el año 23 pero
a largo plazo es un paso que hemos dado
que ha dado la sociedad a que no hay
forma de Volver atrás las energías
renovables como la energía solar y
eólica son competitivas quizás hoy en
día más por los altos precios de los
combustibles fósiles aunque los precios
de esas energías también Los costos han
subido
por las materias y por el costo de las
materias primas y por el alto de la
inflación
todavía es positivas nosotros aquí
estamos una vez más viendo un Horizonte
a largo plazo tres cinco años y vemos
muy positivos la transición energética
para el futuro del del mundo tres a
cinco años de esta transición o de
avances paso a preguntarle a nuestro
invitado aquí en el estudio Luis ferney
como siempre Un gusto tenerlo con
nosotros en el programa bienvenido
también qué lecciones Entonces desde su
punto de vista tenemos que aprender de
este 2022 con muchos altibajos muy bien
muchas gracias por la invitación en
efecto es que estamos viendo estamos
viendo que
definitivamente la guerra en Ucrania ha
impactado la evolución de la transición
energética Europa
porque definitivamente por dos razones
la primera porque ellos pues más
consumen es gas y por supuesto pues ese
impacto de Ucrania afecta el suministro
pero lo interesante aquí es que les tocó
incluso calificar el gas como una
energía renovable de hecho precisamente
porque por por por por la seguridad
energética en Europa y y y en efecto
pues va a estar impactado Eso quiere
decir que en Europa Aunque venían
acelerados en transición pensamos que
pues va a haber un cierto impacto de
usar otro tipo de energéticos como el
carbón como pasa en Alemania que están
usando un poco más carbón ahora
precisamente por amortiguar esa crisis
de Ucrania qué pasa en América Latina
América Latina Pues no va a tener mucho
impacto la guerra pero digamos el
impacto quizás como lo destacaban ahora
mis antecesores es un poco el tema de
las materias primas el costo de la
materia prima si está afectando en
América Latina los precios no tanto la
transición porque la transición de
América Latina estamos pensando es
básicamente en si va a ser rápida o si
va a ser paso a paso paulatino algunos
países van Rápidos como chile los países
pero la mayoría de los países América
Latina van paso a paso de forma
paulatina la transición Le iba a
preguntar para hacer la ronda la inversa
Luis fernay continuó con usted
el 2022 Entonces lo podemos calificar
como un año en el que dimos pasos
pequeños en esa transición en esa
transformación energética y en esa lucha
medioambiental que tenemos que hacer o
es un año en el que claramente dado el
contexto de la Guerra de Ucrania y
esta crisis que está viviendo
principalmente Europa que usted acaba de
Resaltar representa un año en el que
dimos reversa en ese avance tan
necesario que tenemos que dar Cuál es su
perspectiva y bueno de perspectiva para
América Latina concreto
en mi concepto América Latina hay que
distinguir aquellos países un recursos
energéticos los que tienen recursos
energéticos la transición la están
haciendo en nuestro concepto paso a paso
y los que tienen recursos no tienen
recursos energéticos como el caso de
chile otros países Costa Rica que no
tienen recursos energéticos tienen hoy
el gas no tienen petróleo no tienen gas
estos países han acelerado la transición
Entonces el balance de América Latina es
que Quienes no cuentan con petróleo y
gas como un recurso para y dentro del
contexto del medio ambiente
no como no lo cuentan pues ellos
evidentemente están acelerando la
transición y aquellos países como
Colombia que tiene recursos Brasil
Argentina aunque han hecho paso a paso
la transición de toda maneras Es una
transición paulatina como lo señalé
anteriormente pero también Aquí es
importante señalar que la transición
puede generar costos
tiene un costo claro quién va a pagar
todas esas inversiones quien finalmente
lo va a pagar Entonces si todo se
traslada esas inversiones a los usuarios
eso va a impactar la tarifa entonces
legalmente hay que reflexionar en
América Latina si hacemos una transición
rápida eso va a impactar rápidamente en
las tarifas mucho más aún con el efecto
adicional de de las materias primas y si
se hace forma paulatina pues quizás
aunque tenga impacto los usuarios no lo
van a ver tan fuerte en eso paso a
preguntarle a Gustavo en la ciudad de
Panamá y a Jorge también para
complementar la idea entre los dos que
entendamos el panorama que está viviendo
Europa que es tal vez el continente más
más afectado por esta crisis energética
a nivel internacional
lo que significa este 2022 para el
continente europeo vimos como lo
señalaba Luis ferney que Alemania ha
tenido que volver a usar el carbón
activar algunas de sus plantas que ya
estaban cerradas para poder mitigar el
impacto de esta dependencia Ruso y del
petróleo ruso Entonces qué ha
significado para Europa desde su
perspectiva simplemente un año de en el
que han tenido que digamos hacer frente
a la a la crisis de manera inmediata
pero la transición se mantiene a buen
paso o claramente para Europa Esto va a
significar un punto de quiebre y de toma
de decisión acelerar la transición o
demorarla cómo lo ve Gustavo
yo creo que claramente desde la Unión
Europea el consenso ha sido acelerar la
transición y estamos viendo pues cada
vez más nuevos proyectos en cuanto por
ejemplo a temas como el hidrógeno verde
no que nos va a permitir descarbonizar
aquellos sectores como la industria
pesada que son tan difíciles de
descarbonizar y que no los hubiéramos
visto sino hubiera pasado esto no y al
mismo tiempo Pues estamos viendo también
la vuelta a la fabricación tanto de
equipos de paneles solares como de
turbinas eólicas en países como España
que pues tampoco estaban pasando Es más
había habido una emigración desde hace
años hacia Asia no y se habían cerrado
empresas entonces para mí claramente es
una aceleración Sí con algunos pequeños
bajones de volver a utilizar el dignito
por necesidades puntuales en Alemania y
instalar
plantas de lng gas natural licuado en
algunos países pero estamos hablando de
un tema coyuntural temporal porque la
visión es desconectarse de los
combustibles fósiles a medio y largo
plazo y qué piensa Jorge en la ciudad de
Austin en Estados Unidos y le preguntó
también Además del caso europeo
latinoamericano del caso de Estados
Unidos donde el gobierno anterior
liderado por el expresidente Donald
Trump el tema medioambiental lo dejó un
poco de lado Ahora hay un poco más
impulso desde la Casa Blanca por parte
de la Administración biden pero que
tanto se está haciendo Para apoyar esta
transición estos cambios estos planes
que venían en marcha o que simplemente
los dejaron en pausa a raíz de esta
crisis energética que se desató por lo
de Ucrania
Santiago aquí estamos en Texas que como
todos saben es un estado el mayor estado
de producción de petróleo y de gas
natural los Estados Unidos pero también
vale la pena Resaltar que somos el mayor
estado con la mayor producción de
Electricidad eólica
si Texas fuera un país independiente
fuéramos el cuarto mayor productor de
Electricidad eólica Así que aquí puedes
ver donde un mercado que es un mercado
de hidrocarburos hemos podido agregar
nuestra contribución a lo que es la
transición
energética tenemos que tener cuidado de
entender bien lo que está sucediendo en
Europa y cómo puede impactar a América
Latina nosotros una vez más estamos muy
muy optimistas en El Paso de América
Latina en lo que es la transición la
revolución de del hidrógeno
particularmente en países como Chile por
ejemplo eso da paso e indica la
innovación y la tecnología que nuestra
región tiene para desarrollar estas
alternativas Por cierto Los Altos
precios del petróleo
de una forma u otra ayudan a las
energías renovables porque la hacen más
competitivas así todo Aunque algunas de
las materias primas en la construcción
de la energía solar y eólica han
aumentado todavía somos competitivos
aquí en Texas apostamos a la energía
renovables y también en los Estados
Unidos especialmente durante esta
administración Por cierto es importante
también aclarar que los países de
América Latina tienen que demostrar una
continuidad en las políticas Fiscales
para promover las energías renovables
muchos de los gobiernos de la región
tienden a cambiar su política Fiscales
con cambios políticos tienen que
demostrar su compromiso una vez porque
tienen beneficios sociales y beneficios
ambientales que son muy importantes para
la región Jorge continuó con usted
porque usted me lleva justo Exacto al
punto que quería tocar en la siguiente
pregunta y es el compromiso de los
gobiernos los compromisos con los planes
que hay establecidos para darles
continuidad a lo largo de los años en la
región de América Latina y se lo
pregunto porque justamente este 2021 fue
un año electoral en América Latina hay
muchos virajes y cambios de de
alternancia de poder en algunos países
de la región con perspectivas muy
diferentes frente al tema ambiental solo
para poner un ejemplo no mencionó
nombres de gobiernos ni políticas pero
por ejemplo Brasil lo que significó el
gobierno que está saliendo en este
momento y lo que puede significar el
gobierno que entra a partir del primero
de enero Entonces qué se puede decir de
la región de América Latina la
estabilidad de los programas de los
planes la continuidad y sobre todo la
vulnerabilidad de esos programas dada la
coyuntura internacional
Santiago los líderes de esta región
tienen que ver el futuro tienen que
reconocer el impacto de los
hidrocarburos de los de los combustibles
fósiles de la de lo que es la energía
renovable en la región ese futuro lo
tienen que ver tienen que reconocer que
lo que estamos hablando es el futuro de
nuestra juventud y de nuestros hijos y
de nuestros nietos y por eso tenemos que
tener mucho cuidado de que porque lo que
está sucediendo en Europa hoy en día que
yo Espero que no sea un tema de largo
plazo no va a impactar a largo plazo
nuestro nuestro estrategia nuestro
Horizonte aquí en la universidad es el
veinte veinticinco para lo que puede ser
las energías renovables tanto solar como
eólica en la región
hidrógeno estamos llevando la revolución
verde porque es una Revolución verde y
como vemos lo que ha hecho chile eso te
demuestra Santiago lo que nosotros
podemos hacer lo que la región puede
hacer desde el punto de innovación y
tecnología muy importante lo que acabas
de decir los nuevos gobiernos tienen que
continuar apoyando esta nueva transición
energética porque es muy importante para
el futuro de la región cruzó acá el
estudio de France 24 Gustavo ya le doy
la palabra porque quiero tocar con usted
un tema en particular de la región de
América Latina Luis ferney en ese orden
de ideas entendiendo la importancia de
esta continuidad de los planes para
hacer frente a las crisis que se
presenten por las coyunturas qué tan
integrada está la región de América
Latina en términos de planes para
afrontar crisis energéticas o planes de
Cara a esta transición energética Bueno
muy muy buena la pregunta porque estamos
hablando de la integración energética en
América Latina
en nuestro nuestra perspectiva lo que
hemos notado es que falta falta mucho
para llegar a una integración completa
en las Américas en general y en
particular para América Latina porque lo
que tenemos de integración
fundamentalmente mientras Colombia y
Panamá no logren superar esa
interconexión internacional pues muy
difícilmente podemos hablar de una
integración en panamerica la la
transición energética si evaluamos
transacción energéticas y las
interconexiones muy posiblemente el
hecho de que los países empiezan a
trabajar más en políticas de transición
energética muy Posiblemente vaya a
acelerar esa integración energética de
hecho se está hablando mucho el día de
hoy el mismo presidente es Petro por
ejemplo en Colombia en su en su discurso
de Posesión habló de fortalecer las
interconexiones y la integración
energética a propósito de las energías
renovables entonces
la transición En conclusión va a
acelerar más bien la integración
energética en América eso es lo que
esperamos y es el anhelo de hecho es el
anhelo porque el tema que se venía
ventilando hasta el momento era un poco
de so energética pero también hay que
pensar de que las integraciones
energéticas ayudan a la seguridad
energética Ese es el punto importante
ese Esa diferencia que usted hace entre
la soberanía energética y la integración
Gustavo le dejó abierto para que usted
pueda comentar sobre esta apreciación de
Luis Fernan Y si tiene algo para para
Añadir y también para entender otro
punto que le pongo sobre la mesa y es la
desigualdad que hay entre los mismos
países de América Latina que muchos de
ellos todavía hacen que frente a
pequeñas crisis internas no todo el
mundo tiene la facilidad de acceder a
programas de transición energética no
solamente lo que nos golpea de Ucrania
afecta a unos sectores o a otros en
nuestros países seguimos siendo países
muy desiguales en cuanto al tema
energético en cuanto a la lucha
medioambiental Cómo fortalecer esto de
Cara a los próximos años
Bueno pues para mí sigue siendo también
un tema de
soberanía energética Por qué no Y la
única manera de llegar a la soberanía
energética es a través de las energías
renovables que nos permiten ser
independientes de importaciones de
vaivenes económicos de volatilidades
ahora bien el tema que estabas
mencionando antes y Luis no de esa
integración de esas redes esa
interconexión Me parece muy importante
también porque
una de las consecuencias de las energías
renovables es la variabilidad no siempre
eso no siempre hay viento Aunque podemos
con almacenamiento suplir esas
variabilidades entonces pero necesitamos
estar integrados no Entonces
definitivamente ahí queda un espacio
en el que trabajar regionalmente en
muchos beneficios y de hacerlo
fomentaría también el comercio el sector
privado los negocios etcétera etcétera Y
definitivamente con esto que decías tú
de las desigualdades Pues quizá
mencionar que tenemos quizá entre un 5 y
un 10% no de la población de nuestra
región que todavía no tienen acceso a la
electricidad y que una manera de hacer
llegar esta electricidad de una manera
barata y de una manera
sostenible es una vez más de las
energías renovables no de esas micro
redes de esos sistemas a pequeña escala
que podrían hacer llegar la electricidad
aquellas comunidades que no la tienen
no quiero hacerle esa pregunta a Jorge
conocer su punto de vista en torno al
tema de la desigualdad que no solamente
único de América Latina por las
diferencias económicas que hay al
interior de los países esta desigualdad
también la vimos dentro de la Unión
Europea a la hora de negociar la forma
de poderse garantizar el suministro de
gas de cara al invierno vimos países
que no tenían otra salida más que
negociar con Rusia frente a frente a
caso Hungría caso la República Checa
otros países que podían acceder a otros
mercados como Alemania o incluso el
Reino Unido que tenía margen de
negociación con otros países del Golfo
pero algunos países no tienen la
capacidad para ir a negociar con las
grandes economías petroleras del Golfo y
y ahí se vuelve a notar esta desigualdad
energética esta desigualdad en la en la
integración su perspectiva Jorge
no Sí Santiago tenemos que reconocer que
la desigualdad energética existe tanto
en los países pobres como en los países
ricos aquellos que son importadores
netos de energía aquellos que son
exportadores netos de energía Así que
esas desigualdades políticas y
económicas
en regiones como África por ejemplo
América Latina y Europa existen y van a
continuar
existiendo tenemos que recorrer también
recordar también un punto importante que
estamos aquí nosotros estudiando y es el
uso del petróleo en el sector de
transporte y en el sector petroquímico
que son altos contribuyentes al cambio
climático
Recuerda que las renovables parcialmente
contribuyen a lo que es el sector
eléctrico Pero tenemos todavía un gran
consumo de petróleo una vez más en el
sector de transporte y lo que es el
sector
industrial y petroquímico por eso
estamos apostando muy fuerte al
hidrógeno porque es un combustible que
puede ayudar también al sector
transporte no solamente al sector de la
electricidad
pasó aquí al estudio de France 24 con
Luis ferney para preguntarle estas dos
variantes que estamos analizando la
desigualdad la falta de integración y
también la coyuntura de los precios del
petróleo a nivel internacional son
factores de una ecuación
que puede dar como resultado una gran
crisis para el 2023 esto se puede
conjugar en una Tormenta perfecta que
análisis pueda hacer usted bueno esos
tres elementos
digamos
yo nosotros lo que estamos viendo si si
tomamos esos tres elementos es que el
2023 este tema energético se va a
comportar como el 2022
con unos precios que suben bajan
con la misma desigualdad porque hay que
mejorar acceso a energía hay que mejorar
la incluso la capacidad de pago para las
facturas del sector energético porque en
Europa hoy en día se está hablando de
pobreza energética y la pobreza
energética en los países desarrollados
entiende Es la falta de capacidad de
pago y esa falta de capacidad de pago es
obedece a la altas facturas que están
pagando hoy los usuarios en Europa en el
caso nuestro la pobreza energética
hablando de desigualdad se mide en
términos de acceso como bien lo señalaba
mis antecesores Y es que
la desigualdad se miden se empobreza
energética por el acceso a la energía de
nuestro contexto entonces
pensamos de que el año el año entrante
2023 se ha comportar lo mismo que el
2022 es decir vamos a tener precios
volátiles del petróleo vamos a tener que
trabajar mucho más en
mejorar
los fenómenos de desigualdad es decir
trabajar más en evitar la pobreza
energética y En tercer lugar integrarnos
más O sea América Latina sí debe
integrarse más en temas energéticos
Porque pueden complementar pueden
ayudarse en otros países claro me he
enfocado mucho en el tema de la
transición y la parte energética no
quiero dejar de lado el tema de la lucha
contra el cambio climático y le quiero
preguntar a Gustavo Tal vez sea la
pregunta del millón Cómo hacer sobre
todo para estos países de América Latina
y para los países de Europa que están
tan afectados precisamente por la crisis
energética Cómo hacer ese balance entre
cumplir con la lucha contra el cambio
climático y poder garantizar las
necesidades básicas que se están
vale la pena la redundancia se necesitan
en este momento por el invierno boreal
por las bajas temperaturas que se ven en
Europa su perspectiva Gustavo
Bueno pues esas bajas temperaturas que
se ven en Europa pueden ser mitigadas a
través de bombas de calor
o aerotermia que es una tecnología Pues
que utiliza el frío a través de la
electricidad para calentar los hogares Y
en verano hace la inversa no para
enfriarlos y es una tecnología altamente
eficiente utiliza muy poca electricidad
y sirve para Pues el calentamiento de
todo tipo de edificios hogares
industrias etcétera
digamos que la tecnología está ahí Pero
ha habido una política pública muy
influenciada por los
sectores por el lobby fósil del gas
natural
del petróleo que ha impedido a
esta transición en Europa y ahora se
están pagando las consecuencias Entonces
ahora lo que nos preocupa a nosotros es
ver como en América Latina el gas
natural está convirtiéndose en el
combustible principal para la generación
eléctrica en los últimos 10 años la
nueva demanda se ha cubrido se ha
cubierto en prácticamente en un 50% con
gas natural en detrimento de la
generación hidroeléctrica que ha ido
gradualmente bajando y que con el cambio
climático Pues con esa variabilidad de
los patrones de lluvia pues va a bajar
más entonces ese es el gran peligro que
una región que no ha sido dependiente de
un fósil como el gas natural para la
generación eléctrica pues lo vaya a
hacer en el futuro y que seamos la
próxima Europa en un contexto futuro
importante ese punto Gustavo en Ciudad
de Panamá vamos llegando ya el bloque
final de el programa Tengo que
preguntarles por supuesto a mis tres
invitados por ese logro hecho por unos
científicos estadounidenses
en cuanto a la fusión nuclear con
ganancia neta de energía es decir que se
produce una energía
que se produce en el proceso para no sé
no se pierde energía en el proceso de
producción de esta energía fue un hecho
importante destacado a nivel
internacional que puede ser otra vía más
para generar energía con menos impacto
en el medio ambiente Jorge en la ciudad
de Austin esto que puede significar para
el futuro energético para evitar estas
crisis Qué significa esto para para la
humanidad en Sí porque además es un
proceso que todavía le falta unos
cuantos años para poderse consolidar y
poder y poder volverse algo masivo
digámoslo así
Así es yo creo que es una fantástica y
muy buena
estudio que que dio resultado del
departamento de energía de los Estados
Unidos a esta noticia desde el punto de
vista de tecnología e ingeniería es lo
que se está trabajando ahora para
desarrollar esperamos en los próximos
cinco años lo importante va a ser la
comercialización de esta energía que
también nosotros estamos viendo ahora el
desarrollo técnico de ingeniería y de
aplicación va a durar por lo menos tres
o cinco años pero lo importante ahora es
cómo se comercializa esa nueva energía
no solamente dentro de los países ricos
europeos y América del Norte pero en el
resto de la región excelente noticia una
vez más un Nuevo Horizonte a largo plazo
Por eso tenemos que tener muy mucho
cuidado en enfocarnos en lo que va a
pasar aquí en los próximos dos años dos
el año veinticinco y el año 30 van a ser
muy importantes en estos futuros
desarrollos de energía Bueno una
perspectiva positiva por el lado de
Jorge por acá en el estudio Luis ferney
su opinión Bueno muy bien yo Considero
que definitivamente hay un hecho
evidente claro a nivel global
todos estamos obligados
a cumplir unos compromisos
internacionales todos los países en su
mayoría
del fenómeno del cambio climático por
eso se ha construido toda una sistema
regulatorio internacional que los países
lo ha venido acogiendo y en desarrollo
de ello lo que estamos viendo Es que los
países han empezado unos más que otros a
impulsar una serie de fuentes a
propósito de lo que usted preguntaba de
esta fuente de obra nuclear de unas
nuevas de unas fuentes energéticas bajan
emisiones es decir la narrativa el día
de hoy es Buscar Fuentes y recursos
bajan emisiones en eso Entonces
incluimos por ejemplo la energía
renovables pero no solamente en es
renovables incluimos el hidrógeno
incluimos incluso la energía de origen
vegetal incluimos incluso la tecnología
de captura de misiones e incluso hay que
incluir este tipo de Propuesta que han
hecho
en Estados Unidos estos científicos
porque todo eso con tener una serie de
fuentes la humanidad tener una fuente
una fuente de energía baja en emisiones
importante aclarar es que todo eso hace
parte de la transición energética pero
la transición energética no es un fin lo
que es el fin la transición energética
es un medio para lograr un fin el fin
Cuál es que la humanidad tengamos
energía pero una energía limpia
sostenible y en ese sentido podemos
convivir En este planeta Entonces en ese
en ese contexto consideramos de que
bienvenida el estudio la mayoría de los
estudios entre otras por una pequeña
razón y con esto termino y es que se ha
hablado mucho de eficiencia energética
pero es eficiencia energética al lado de
la demanda y aquí lo que estamos
logrando con esta descubrimientos de
estos científicos norteamericanos es que
también se tiene que hacer eficiencia
energética también a nivel de la
producción energética entonces me parece
interesante eso importante ese punto
Gustavo
preguntarle por este mismo punto este
logro de estos científicos
estadounidenses y de inmediato también
le le propongo que hagamos las
conclusiones ya me quedan par minutas
para finalizar el programa lo que se
viene entonces en el 2023 con el
contexto en el que estamos la coyuntura
en la que estamos qué cree usted que
vamos a vivir en temas energéticos Y
cómo va a terminar este invierno para
Europa
gracias Bueno pues tu primera pregunta
Pues un logro científico muy importante
sin embargo esto no nos cambia el
panorama en cuanto lo que tenemos que
hacer para abaratar los precios
energéticos y para mitigar el cambio
climático que es pasar a las energías
renovables estamos hablando de que esta
fusión nueva fusión limpia segura
etcétera etcétera pues va a ser
comercializada en un plazo demasiado
lejano como para tener un impacto ahora
mismo Entonces que no sea que no nos
distraiga de lo que hay que hacer ahora
mismo de acuerdo eso va a seguir su
propia ruta y ya veremos A dónde nos
llega y con respecto a las conclusiones
el próximo año Pues mira nosotros desde
Naciones Unidas tenemos Claro que si
queremos conseguir un calentamiento no
mayor de 5 grados en la segunda mitad
del siglo tenemos que reducir en los
próximos ocho años un 50% las emisiones
globales de gases de efecto invernadero
Llevamos una dirección contraria las
estamos aumentando en vez de reducirla
entonces lo que necesitamos es aumentar
la ambición para poner en marcha todas
estas tecnologías Y eso significa dejar
de explorar combustibles fósiles
petróleo y gas sobre todo y dedicar ese
mismo recurso que se está dedicando a
promover el cambio climático a generar
tormentas tropicales sequías cosas que
nos van a crear una desestabilización
planetaria de una magnitud enorme esa
misma plata hay que dedicarla a promover
las energías renovables y el transporte
limpio aumentar la ambición esa frase me
quedo con esa frase gustado Jorge
rápidamente en su conclusión
No no estoy de acuerdo con Gustavo es
decir Tenemos que tener Buena vista
hacia el futuro va a ser un futuro
prometedor como dijo él de los próximos
cinco u ocho años así que tenemos
contratiempo a corto plazo Tenemos que
tener nuestros gobiernos que tengan
continuidad de las políticas Fiscales y
también de sus acuerdos que todos ellos
han firmado para un planeta verde y un
planeta limpio así que no optimismo a
este lado contratiempo lo vamos a
superar optimismo Jorge me quedo con esa
frase por este lado para el cierre Luis
fernay Bueno yo Considero que
definitivamente hay que estimular
promover
las inversiones En la transición
energética para que contribuyan a
mitigar el cambio climático pero no
solamente quedarnos en la
descarbonización nosotros consideramos
de que también hay que pensar en el
almacenamiento de energía aprovechar
esas nuevas tecnologías de
almacenamiento que pues para
complementarle a Jorge y a Gustavo que
pues como expertos en estos temas saben
de que esto es muy importante el
almacenamiento y también importantes
esas Fuentes descentralizadas fuentes de
producción de energía que se están dando
a nivel de los puntos de consumo también
entonces todo esto realmente nos ayudará
quizás viendo una posición optimista que
los los seres humanos podamos tener
energía
aprovechando la descarbonización el
almacenamiento la descentralización de
fuentes y otras cosas más que aquí los
científicos están contribuyendo Muchas
gracias a Luis ferney y a Jorge y a
Gustavo por haber estado con nosotros
les agradezco nos acompañaron el
programa ustedes Muchísimas gracias por
la sintonía la producción estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera siga con France 24
[Música]